[Music]
[Applause]
hello jeaious Kampf holy cow there are
so many of you this is the biggest
conference I've ever been to and it is
also I'm embarrassed to say this is my
first J has come my JS can't be you I
kept trying to come but I had like
immigration issues and all sorts of
stuff and I made it just in time for the
last one
so I'm extra specially thrilled to be
here and be invited to speak but before
we get started the way that I don't die
of nervousness is I always take a
speaker selfie but there's millions of
you so I'm gonna take a bunch look happy
like you just heard the best talk of
your life amazing all right with that
important business out of the way hello
everybody i'm laurie i am the co fun of
the cofounders of npm inc i'm currently
the chief data officer there but what I
really AM is a web developer making the
web bigger and better and more
accessible to everyone is what really
drives me and it's been driving me for
23 years now which means sometimes I
meet people who are younger than my web
development career which is weird and
today I'm here to talk about JavaScript
I'm going to talk about who we are I'm
gonna the people who write JavaScript
I'm gonna talk about where we use
javascript and what we're doing with it
today and also I'm gonna talk about why
the forces that are driving us to the
state that we're in right now and then
finally I'm gonna talk about what comes
next
looking at current trends and guessing
where they're going the goal of this
talk is to give you a sense of
perspective about the state of
JavaScript as a whole and where you sit
in it
so many developers work in a vacuum we
don't know if the thing that we're doing
is a best practice or if it's a fad or
if it's this hopelessly out of date
thing that nobody does anymore so I'm
hoping you'll leave this talk feeling
good about one thing that you're using
knowing that it's a really good thing
with feeling that you should move away
from one thing that you're using and
also excited about learning one new
thing that you haven't heard about or
you hadn't decided to get into before
but before I say all of that stuff it's
worth asking how I know where did I get
all of this information we have three
main sources for the stuff I'm about to
present the first is the NPM registry
stats the NPM registry contains amazing
data about what JavaScript developers
are up to on what they're using and we
also did a survey our first annual
survey got 16,000 responses and our
second got 33,000 responses so we have
an enormous amount of information of
people just telling us what you're up to
and why you're doing it and I also
supplemented and double-checked our
numbers using the excellent state of
JavaScript survey run by the community
and I also have one final surprise
source which is 10 years of genius
confit you talk proposals 10 years my
goodness that is so much work can we
have another round of applause for 10
years
[Applause]
as part of the celebration of the 10th
year of Jays convey you the organizers
asked me to analyze the data they gave
me all of the titles and descriptions of
all of the talks that have ever been
submitted to J as Khan for you and they
were like can you find something
interesting in this and boy did I find a
lot of interesting things in this first
off there are so many talks this year
the first day is comfy you had 44 talks
submitted and this year there were 932
in 2016 there was no J's coffee you they
took a break and in 2012 somebody had
the bright idea of suggesting that
people submit their talks as JSON which
was a goddamn nightmare to parse back
out into text and sentences so thank you
to whoever's bright eye there that was
the single most common phrase I could
walk right the single most common phrase
in the last 10 years has been in this
talk we will and the second most common
phrase was learn how to and sometimes it
was both but there's something much more
interesting which is the jeaious coffee
you hypo meter I wanted to track how
popular various technologies were but of
course since there are more talks every
year every single technology gets it you
know mentioned more and more often right
like everything is going up into the
right so instead I measured how many
talks contain a word as a percentage of
all of the talks submitted so this is an
example of one it's of node and NPM as
you can see we're talking about node
much less than we used to but we're
talking about NPM about the same as much
as we ever did so all through this talk
I'm gonna weave in the J's conf data and
we'll see how much what we're talking
about lines up with the reality of what
we're actually doing but Laurie I hear
you say you had a huge corpus of text
you could have built a Markov generator
you bet your asset built a Markov
generator
here for your pleasure are some machine
generated titles based on all of the
previous submissions to JS conf that you
can use for your submissions to future
conferences train your next-level
JavaScript sequential arts this is
definitely going to be done by jeniffer
complex applications talk about tools
for capitalism I think it's possible
that CJ Silverio has already written
this talk distributed computing in the
world of CSS and Jas it's possible they
did this yesterday I wasn't here yet amp
for why you are being an eyebrow
malte is going to handle this one
serverless a lisp i don't know what this
means but I bet that somebody could talk
for 25 minutes and persuade me that it's
true and finally go node and JavaScript
script oh I don't know what it is but
it's probably a bad idea and I am
looking forward to seeing all of these
conference notes in future and finally
before we dive in just a couple of
disclaimers some of what I'm presenting
here are facts and some of what I'm
presenting here our opinions and I've
tried to be as clear as possible which
is which and when I'm doing which one so
sometimes you're gonna see a graph that
says that your favorite technology is
getting less popular and what I'm asking
is that you don't get mad about that
don't get mad about facts I have so many
opinions so many terrible opinions that
you can get mad about but try not to get
mad about the facts I do not have a
horse in this race apart from NPM I am
NOT a contributor to any of the
technologies I'm discussing I'm just
presenting the facts secondly a lot of
what I'm talking about involves relative
popularity of technologies and I want to
make clear that just because the
technology is popular doesn't mean that
it's good it doesn't mean that it's the
best technology I don't even know what
the best technology means but for
technology popularity is useful in and
of itself if there are a lot of people
using your technology then there will be
a lot of people helping find and fix
bugs there will be a lot of tutorial
so it'll be a lot of Stack Overflow
questions answered for you if you work
with something popular it often makes
your work easier regardless of how good
it really is and finally I really love
this stuff I really love what I talk
about and I'm going to get very excited
towards the end so I'm probably going to
swear like an absolute [ __ ] sailor
and I have no intention of changing that
or toning it down in any way
so just apologies in advance so let's
get started who are we JavaScript
developers the answer is at this point
we're pretty much like everybody else
we look if you look at our demographics
we are the same age distribution the
same industry profile we live in all of
the same countries as all other software
developers and the reason for that is
because we nearly are all software
developers we are 11 million developers
now writing JavaScript every day and
those 11 million developers are using
more open source software than any other
language community the NPM registry is
now the largest repository of open
source of any kind
by any measure by number of modules by
lines of code number of users whatever
you want to pick it's more than twice as
big as the next registry in fact you
could fold all of the other registries
into our registry if you wanted but does
having a really big registry of open
source software translate to other kinds
of activity on github javascript is the
biggest language by number of
repositories by a number of issues by a
number of lines of code and it has been
for seven years in a row in stack
overflows huge developer survey of
80,000 people javascript was the most
popular language with 68% of all
developers saying that they write
javascript at least some of the time of
course you're all at a JavaScript
conference so that you knew that
javascript was popular already but here
is the truth javascript is the most
popular programming in the world
language in the world right now and
there are more developers than ever
before so javascript is really the most
popular programming language there has
ever been
and as JavaScript continues to grow the
JavaScript community is changing one
thing we noticed has changed between our
survey and 2018 and the one that we do
and the last one we did is that
JavaScript developers are getting more
experienced they've been writing
JavaScript for longer we especially
noticed this with NPM itself a year ago
half of all NPM users were new which is
to say they'd been using NPM for less
than two years and this year only about
36 percent of people are round about
2014 and 2015 there was a massive spike
in the number of NPM users around about
that time is when JavaScript existing
JavaScript developers sort of tuned in
to NPM and the existing pool of
JavaScript developers all sort of
adopted NPM on mass but today the number
of new NPM users and the number of new
JavaScript users they look about the
same because basically anybody who
learns JavaScript in 2019 is learning
NPM at the same time so now we believe
that about 99 percent of JavaScript
developers are using NPM and that's part
of why NPM has so much information about
what JavaScript developers are up to
this ever-growing pool of increasingly
experienced JavaScript developers means
that we've also seen a shift in what
JavaScript developers care about we knew
from analyzing last year's data that
more experienced developers care more
about best practices they do more
testing they use more linters and
bundlers they care more about security
and so now the whole community is
getting more experience and so everybody
is caring more about those sorts of
things since last year's survey the
number of people who said that they were
concerned about the open the security of
the open-source modules that they use
has increased in the last two years
NPM has added two factor auth to help
protect package publishers from account
theft as well as a security team and
automation behind the scenes to detect
and flag malicious packages but
malicious packages are not really the
good threat model accidental
vulnerabilities are much much more
common so last year we introduced the
NPM audit command which will find and
fix security vulnerabilities in your
application by upgrading to more secure
versions of the packages that are out
there we have performed 335 million
security audits in the last 30 days and
if you think that your company should be
doing more about security you'll forgive
me if I mention that we have a booth at
this conference and we have a product
called NPM Enterprise and it can help
your company do more about JavaScript
security than it's currently doing and
that brings us to our first visit to the
hi-po meter I said that we care more
about security so are we talking more
about security the answer is no in fact
the thing that we talk about is
performance we talk about performance
three times more than we talk about
security but if we care more about
security we should probably be talking
more about it another aspect of our
increasingly experienced user base is
that people actually care what software
license they use that was a big surprise
to me I just like to throw it in there
without thinking about it but 58% of
developers say that the software license
affects their their decision to use a
piece of open-source software and of
those people 55% say that their company
prevents them using certains open-source
software licenses so that means that 29%
of people overall can't use certain
software licenses which software
licenses well the GPL and the a GPL are
unpopular because of the restrictions
that they place on commercial use of
software but much bigger than that was
unrecognized licenses basically anybody
who cares about software licenses has
had to hire a lawyer to tell them which
software licenses are ok so if you use
some software license that they've never
heard of before they have to hire the
lawyer again and they don't want to do
that so they just don't use your
software so if your licensing your
software please for the license on your
software and please pick a big popular
license that people have heard of and
the final aspects of who we are that I
want to touch on is a consequence of how
ubiquitous Java
script has become in 2019 which is that
25% of JavaScript developers say that
javascript is not their primary language
javascript is so popular to become
inescapable which means that there are
lots of JavaScript developers who aren't
writing JavaScript by choice
they're writing it because they have to
and that is going to show up in a bunch
of places and this data that I'm about
to present so what are these other
languages that the non primary
JavaScript developers are writing well
top of the list is type scripts we're
gonna talk more about typescript in a
bit but there's also lots of Python and
Java and c-sharp and C++ in there a fun
fact is that 12% of JavaScript
developers don't write any other
languages they're just all JavaScript
all the time but 88% of us are writing
JavaScript and some other language at
least one more so now we've covered who
we are we are all over the world where
every agent experience we're
increasingly sophisticated we care more
about licensing and security where are
we writing all of this javascript the
answer is every goddamn place that you
can imagine so first let's go to the
hypo meter do people at JS conf talk
more about front-end or back-end well it
turns out there's a battle going on it's
been up and down but for the last three
years
front-end has been winning how does that
stack up to the facts pretty well 97% of
JavaScript developers are writing code
for browsers 77% of JavaScript
developers are also writing code for
servers so nodejs
still a big deal in the community but
there are two surprises in here and the
first is that 46% of JavaScript
developers are writing native apps I
don't mean progressive web apps I don't
mean like a shortcut to a web app that
you put on your home screen I mean
they're compiling it down to some other
thing and it's running natively on a
desktop or it's running natively on a
phone and 13% of us are writing embedded
applications stuff that runs on handsets
or watches or you know stuff that you
wear so let's dig more into all of these
numbers first off when people write for
browsers
do they target the mobile web or do they
target the desktop web well the
overwhelming majority of us target both
but despite all our talk about mobile
first only 2% of us target exclusively
mobile but 27% of us are getting away
without thinking about the mobile web at
all which is probably legitimate there
are probably a bunch of web apps that
are just never gonna run on a phone and
that's fine but now let's talk about
native apps 46% of JavaScript developers
are writing native apps as you can see
the biggest group is mobile developers
35% of us are writing native mobile apps
and 26% of us are writing native desktop
apps and a big chunk of us are doing
both so what are we using to do that
first let's look at the desktop
developers 26% of apps of developers say
they write native desktop apps but here
we have a bit of a puzzle
you've all probably heard of
electron-electron it's a popular way of
writing native desktop apps but only 21%
of us say that we use it which means
that there's 5% of us who are writing
native desktop applications in
JavaScript and they're using something
other than electron I don't know what it
is that 21% of electron users is down
from 24% of users so not only is it that
we're not using electron we're using
less electron than before so where are
they going let's swing by the hypo meter
and ask it about electrons sure enough
the hypo meter says that interest
electron peaked around 2017 and has been
going down since then so what is up
somebody needs to tell me if you know
what it is that they're doing please
come and talk to me after this and now
let's look at native app developer
mobile app developers I measured the
popularity of a bunch of frameworks
don't pay too much attention to how I
measured it the Green Line is all native
app frameworks so native development has
been staying pretty much as popular as
before but the tools have fragmented the
most popular framework that I can find
is react native which is that red line
and then there's Cordova which is the
line in yellow it used to be the only
game in town for native mobile apps but
now it's just a little bit less popular
than react native
extrapolating from our data between 13%
and 19% of NPM developers are using
Cordova and about 19% are using react
native and those two add up to about the
35% of us who are writing native mobile
apps but if you're using some other
framework I want to know the final where
question that I want to answer is about
server side apps where are we deploying
them unsurprisingly docker and
kubernetes are everybody's jam these
days they're the dominant way that we
deploy deployment platforms like Heroku
and natla PHY stuff like that they're
also super popular VMs are surprisingly
unpopular for what I used to consider to
be the default way of deploying software
but the real number here is serverless
33% of us are deploying on serverless
platforms that is not some you know
early adopter [ __ ] anymore that is a
mainstream technology and it's part of a
broader trend in deploying that I'm
gonna touch on later but let's check out
the hypo meter I decided to look at
serverless micro services and docker
micro services is that line in red you
can see that we've sort of stopped
talking about it
docker came strong out of the gate in
2015 but it has slowed down recently but
serverless is on the up-and-up that's
the blue line but isn't circle it's just
like a micro service that somebody else
is running for you I mean I don't know
anyway that brings us to the end of
where now let's talk about what what are
we doing with all of this stuff I'm
gonna try and keep this section also as
factual as possible
and keep my opinions out of it to
measure this stuff I use a metric called
share of registry yeah I use it in that
graph a little while ago it's a very
useful metric but it's also kind of a
confusing metric so I'm going to explain
it a bit this is a graph of the weekly
downloads from the NPM registry we do
nearly 12 billion downloads every single
week and that has grown by 25,000
percent since 2014
and this presents something of a problem
if you're trying to measure how popular
something is using just download numbers
because download numbers always go up
here is a graph of downloads of some
major front-end frameworks and they're
all growing pretty fast in absolute
terms in fact everything and the
registry grow is super fast even the
shittiest package in the registry is
constantly acquiring new users because
there's just so many people showing up
all the time and going out I don't know
what I'm gonna use I'm going to use evil
packet genius this is great so absolute
growth won't work so just like with the
J's confer submissions we're using
relative popularity we use the
percentage who downloads of a package as
a percentage of all of the downloads and
that is what we call share of registry
so here is the same graph again using
the share of registry metric instead
suddenly what's going on is a lot more
clear some stuff is going up some stuff
is staying flat some stuff is going down
but it's important to remember that
going down is not actually declining it
just means that it's going up more
slowly staying flat on this graph means
that you grew 25,000 percent and if
you're going up on this graph it means
that you were growing faster than 25,000
percent so growing up is growing
incredibly fast so now let's talk about
these frameworks the story of front-end
frameworks in 2019 is pretty simple and
it is that react has conquered the web
react has more than four times as many
downloads is the next most popular
framework there has never been a
framework anything like this popular and
part of the reason for that is that it's
not just a front-end framework in fact
it's not even a front-end framework
react is just a component model and that
component model is used in web apps but
also in react native apps and also in
desktop apps and this is just the
Downloads data what about the survey
where we asked actual people
in our survey 63% of JavaScript
developers say that they are using react
but using is a vague term right like it
could be anything
so we asked a more specific question and
57% of people say that they write reacts
themselves 6% say they use react written
by other people but more interestingly
15% of us say that we don't use reacts
yet but we are considering it
so reacts already a ridiculously
dominant framework still has room to
grow apparently although the share of
registry appears to be slowing down so
we don't know what yet which one of
those things is going to happen to dig
even further we ask people how much they
write react inside the 15 4 7 57% of
people who write react 49 percent say
they primarily write react and which
means 26% of all NPM users are primarily
building react and if you add in the
people who write it only sometimes that
means that 47% nearly half of all
JavaScript developers are writing react
some or most of the time there has never
been a framework of which that is true
that is a strange and new situation for
JavaScript to be in moving on to the
other frameworks last year I got into
some trouble because I took angular
version 1 and angular version 2 onwards
and I treated them as a single framework
called angular and I was strenuously
informed that that is incorrect angular
version one is called angularjs now
angular version 2 onwards is also is a
totally different framework completely
unrelated to the first one also called
angular which I still think is kind of
confusing but as you can see angularjs
has been in decline since 2016 and
angular 2 plus has been in decline since
2017 but it's important to keep in mind
that this is relative popularity in
absolute terms both of these frameworks
are still growing up both of these
frameworks have more users than they've
ever had before angular is extremely
popular 30
percent of NPM users say they use some
flavor of angular 29 percent of NPM
users say that they use the current
version of angular that means that
there's probably about three million
people using angular which is definitely
nothing to sneeze at and angular is not
going anywhere let's look at one more
framework of note which is view view is
the only major framework other than
react showing strong positive growth but
it is very positive growth its share of
registry has doubled in the last two
years which means that it's downloads
grew 10x in that time at our survey data
backs it's up 27% of NPM users say that
they use view and that's up from 24%
last year which means that almost as
many people use view as use the current
version of angular so let's swing by the
hypo meter and see what they had to say
about front-end frameworks
unsurprisingly in 2009 everybody was
talking about dojo and jQuery but we
don't talk about those things anymore
angular ember and reacts trajectories
you can see them they all match pretty
well to their share of registry which is
nice
angular's decline starts in 2015 that's
in red ember is pretty flat in yellow
and reacts in blue is continuing to grow
just like it is in the registry data one
thing I haven't talked about in terms of
front-end frameworks is web components
and part of that is web components are
built into browsers so there's no share
of registry to track right like nobody's
downloading them but the other reason is
they just don't seem to be very popular
we didn't ask about them an NPM survey
which is embarrassing but the state of
JSP Ville did they act they allowed
people to volunteer if they used web
components but less than 1% of people
did so I'm not ignoring web components
they just don't I don't have very good
data about them the people who build web
components in browsers they tell me that
web components are a lot more popular
than I think they are but of course they
would say that so moving from the front
end to the back end there has been a
real revolution previously if I was
talking about backends frameworks out of
talked about stuff like sails and ember
and happy and those things are still
around and they still have pretty much
flat growth which is to say 25,000
percent growth there
going anywhere but everybody's writing
rich front-end apps and frameworks like
those that produce static views are just
not as useful for that use case anymore
so instead what's happened is front-end
framework enthusiasts realized that they
needed to deliver pre-rendered HTML for
performance reasons and they called it
server-side rendering or SSR and they
invented stuff to do that which is to
say they invented backends so now the
front-end frameworks are all also
back-end frameworks collections of
servers and routers that make it easy to
build a full server using your favorite
framework and I don't know what about
you but the idea that I can just write
components and then throw them into an
existing framework and not have to that
does all of the serving and the parsing
and all of that pain-in-the-ass stuff
for me that's great but it's also super
familiar I'm pretty sure that's how PHP
used to work someday soon somebody is
going to tell me that I can just FTP my
react components onto a server and then
the circle will be complete before I
talk about these SSL frameworks
it's important to note that they were
all still pretty small here for
comparison is Express Express is a
goddamn monster of a package
it used to be 1.5 percent of the
registry all by itself and it is still
enormous all of the other frameworks
that I'm about to talk about that flat
line at the bottom of the graph that you
can barely see but when you take Express
out of the picture something very
interesting is happening at the top of
our list is Gatsby it uses react and it
provides a whole set of tools for
hooking it up to backends and deploying
it gatsby snuck up on us we didn't ask
about it at all last year and we asked
about it this year 8% of people were
using it so clearly we should have been
paying attention sooner for comparison
frameworks that I used to talk about
like sales and ember and happy they're
all around the 4% 5% area so Gatsby is
bigger than those now it is huge it's
real and it is growing like gangbusters
the other frameworks that I want to talk
about our trio of back-end frameworks
which all have nearly the same name
in a way that is not irritating and
confusing at all first up is next Jas
which is another react based back-end
framework our survey respondents were
very big on next year's about nine
percent of them said that they use it
share registry is giving gatsby the edge
at the moment though but clearly they're
both very popular and then there's nuts
to jeaious with au which is very much
like next except it's for view instead
of react five percent of the devs in our
survey said that they were using it and
then there's nest Jay s with an S which
is like next Jay us except it's for
angular I know very little bit about
very little about it I didn't ask about
it in our survey but extrapolating from
the data about two percent of people are
using nest jeaious and it's also showing
pretty healthy growth but what about the
height let's go to the hypo meter well
it's super frustrating because next is
just a word people say next all the time
they don't mean the framework and nest
shows up all the time cuz people talk
about nested loop and nested code so I
couldn't search for that either so this
is just a graph of gatsby and it's
super-hype only four people ever have
submitted talks about next closely
related to these front-end frameworks
which are now back-end frameworks is
graph QL which is the hot new way of
building an API to power all of this
stuff as you can see graph QL score
library and two of its most popular
client libraries are all growing off the
charts super fast in share of registry
and that climb is reflected in the
survey data 22% of our respondents say
that they are using graph QL but 49
percent say that they are considering
using graph QL which is an enormous
number it means that 2019 is going to be
the year of graph QL when everybody gets
onboard the Train and the final set of
trend data that we're going to look at
is the hottest trend of all which is not
writing JavaScript anymore
remember all those non primary
JavaScript developers that I was talking
about especially the ones coming from
typed languages like Java and c-sharp
and C++ this is how they're influenced
is showing up the biggest part of this
trend is typescript
last year we were caught by surprise
when 49% of people said sorry 46% of
people said that they use type scripts
and this year that number is up to 63%
but what does using mean do you really
mean you're using it are you writing it
what are you doing with it exactly we
asked in more detail it turns out 15% of
people are just using things that are
written in typescript and the main
culprit there is angular angular is
written in typescript so everybody who
uses angular reports themselves as a
typescript user in fact reacts an ember
both have typescript in them now so the
only major framework that doesn't have
some typescript in it is view but even
if you say that you write typescript do
you mean you write it all the time or
just to try it out are you using it you
know are you a typescript dev or are you
just a typescript dabbler with in
typescript developers 52% of them
primarily write typescript
which means and another 34% are writing
typescript some of the time which means
that overall 36% of NPM users are
writing type scripts most or all of the
time which is a tremendous change a
third of javascript users don't write
javascript anymore that's amazing
incidentally one of the features of
typescript is that it has these type
definition files and those type
definition files are hosted on the
registry under the type scope and the
last time I checked 2.5 percent of all
registry downloads or type definitions
the most downloaded they're mostly
downloaded automatically by BS code so
we should probably have a chat with
Microsoft about that but what about the
hype the hype is doing fine for fun I
throw in CoffeeScript which is the last
time somebody tried to replace
JavaScript with something that looks
kind of like JavaScript we all talk
about CoffeeScript anymore the other
part of the not writing JavaScript trend
is webassembly
gen Schafer is giving a talk later today
but the basic idea is that web assembly
is a technology that lets you take any
compiled language and run it on the web
at near native speeds there's two things
people find interesting about that the
first is the speed and the second is but
the people who write web assemblies say
that that is less interesting than the
second part which is the ability to use
existing code written in other languages
directly on the web to me one of the
most exciting features
webassembly is that you can write
modules for it and publish them to the
NPM registry and install them into your
app and just use them seamlessly without
knowing that they're there and the way
that I know you can do that is it
already happened our stats say that
webassembly is still very new only about
3% of use people people say they use it
but that's 300,000 people and only point
zero six percent of the packages in the
registry or azzam but that's 600
packages some of which are very cool but
the big number for webassembly is 54%
that is how many people say that they
are considering using it which means
that the interest in webassembly is
enormous so now we know who we are and
what we're using and those facts key
that together can point us towards some
explanations as to why this is where I
switch from facts to analysis which is
to say opinions which is to say I am
wrong but before I do that I need to
split the room up into two teams
everybody on this side of the room is
team a everybody on this side of the
room is team B let me hear it from team
a team B team a team B great I'm not
using that for anything was just to wake
you up after 30 minutes of graphs the
first question to answer is why is
JavaScript the most popular programming
language I think we can discard the idea
that it's the best designed programming
language one answer is the NPM registry
a guy called Leo meyerovich did a study
in which he researched why people use
programming languages is it because of
the features of the speed or because
their boss forced them to and the number
one reason was the existence of open
source libraries in that language if
there's a library that helps you get the
job done you adopt the language of the
library and because there are so many
libraries in it in Java scripts already
it keeps sucking people in once about
every 15 minutes somebody sends me this
picture thinking that it's super
hilarious and I won't have seen it
before but it's not a bad metaphor
every time somebody adds another another
package to the pile it increases the
gravity well another developer gets
sucked in and that developer
Greece's the pull even further and this
has created a new type of JavaScript
developer The Reluctant JavaScript sir
they were once a really small group but
now they're a quarter or possibly even
more of the JavaScript developer
population they don't write JavaScript
because they like it they write
JavaScript because they have to and
that's bad that's bad for them because
they hate it and it's bad for us because
people who hate JavaScript won't write
it well why are we forcing people to
write JavaScript this happened one time
before a few years ago Ruby developers
found themselves sucked into the
JavaScript world and they [ __ ] hated
it they hate javascript and they keep
telling me that they hate it and there's
in the survey results and some of them
attempted to resolve that problem by
inventing CoffeeScript but the Ruby
folks mostly won even though we don't
use CoffeeScript anymore javascript is
full of features that we used to have
income in Ruby and typescript is
something like that pattern remember all
of those non primary JavaScript
developers a bunch of people from typed
languages in particular from Java and
c-sharp they miss the types and so
typescript is giving them the types back
that's what they like about it and given
typescript given the popularity of types
and type scripts and Microsoft's backing
in particular it is unlikely to go
anywhere in our survey seventeen percent
of people who had heard of webassembly
said part of why they were interested in
web assembly is it event that they
wouldn't have to write JavaScript
anymore webassembly frees developers
from javascript and the result will be
that a lot of people will stop writing
javascript but that is not something to
be worried about
first not everybody is going to stop
just the folks who hated writing it and
second when people writing web assembly
are looking for a way to share code the
NPM registry is the natural way for them
to do that web assembly will make
JavaScript stronger by giving it access
to the best libraries from every other
language which is a tremendously
exciting idea
the next question we're touching on is
what the hell is going on with react
part of the explanation is that react
isn't a full web framework it has no
opinions about routing or data models
like other frameworks do so as data
models and routing models
change it means that people can keep
using their react components as they
shift and go and change within that
group it's just a component model and it
creates truly reusable useful components
these are two examples that I
particularly like a color picker and a
date picker I [ __ ] hate implementing
both of those and I can just npm install
them now oh my god that's so great that
has been the dream for 20 years
other projects provide libraries of
excellent pre-built components this is
one that does it for Google's material
UI reach UI is an excellent start on
making reactive components more
accessible but react can go even further
now with reactive hooks which are a way
of handling state that you can just npm
install into your application react to
use is a library that gives you a whole
bunch of really cool stuff without
having that uses the web api is without
you having to write a bunch of code you
can just import it and start using it in
your react app this suggests an enticing
future where we can build web apps at a
new and higher level of abstraction we
won't have to think too hard about the
server we can just put existing
components together instead of building
them from scratch for each project and
each new component that we add to the
pile of react components will create the
same feedback loop as NPM itself the
more components there are the stronger
the gravity well and the more developers
there will be in that community this
could make react an unstoppable force
that changes web development forever but
it's not guaranteed
reiax growth seems to be slowing down
and view is showing strong growth so is
view the future will react to decline
and fade like every javascript framework
ever before in the next couple of years
we get to find out but meanwhile Reax
dominance on the front end has totally
changed the backend as i showed earlier
frameworks that enable server-side
rendering of react apps are now more
popular than traditional back-end
frameworks instead of writing code for
client and server we just write code for
the client and we get the server to deal
with it and figure it out is that a good
idea
is building all web apps as rich
front-end apps and then getting the
server to do the work a good idea I
don't know but it's certainly a popular
idea and
hilarity is its own momentum at least
one browser maker is already working on
specific optimizations to make react
apps faster at the browser level last
year I made the I made the case that
react components should become part of
the Web API and I stand by that so let's
take all these trends analysis and weave
them together and let's make some
guesses about the future so I'm gonna go
from slightly wrong to completely wrong
the first is a future I don't have to
guess about which is NP x NPM [ __ ] cat
we'll be giving a talk about it later
it's a tremendously exciting thing that
I don't have time to demo Dan Abramov
tweeted this in a few tweeted this a few
days ago and it was just perfect because
it's exactly where all of this looks
like it might be going imagine a world
where you can build a web app without
needing to know all the details of how
all of your components work people hate
on vb6 but vb6 was at one point the
world's most popular programming
language and that's us now vb6
unlocked and created a whole generation
of programmers by reducing the barrier
to entry think how many more people
could get involved if you could build a
real useful web app by just dragging and
dropping open-source components into
your application this wouldn't make your
job obsolete we would still need
everyone in this room to be writing
components but we would need a room ten
times this size to hold all the people
who would be using those components a
whole new level of abstraction a whole
new kind of web developer that is a
tremendously exciting idea and then you
add to that mix web assembly which is
still early days right now but you could
bring every useful library from every
other language into the JavaScript world
and make them all interoperable with no
performance it suddenly not only is it
easier to build apps but what you can
build is vastly expanded and the last
piece of the puzzle is all those native
app developers already nearly half of us
take highly performant rich web apps and
suddenly don't just run them on the
browser run them on your phone run them
on your shoes run them on your VR
headset wherever
javascript running everywhere absorbing
every language into a unified world of
open-source components built by an
ever-expanding and increasingly diverse
community of developers there's no
guarantee that will happen but I can
imagine a world where it does and after
23 years of watching the web grow no
time has ever been more exciting than
right now and you my friends and
colleagues are perfectly placed you're
in the right place at the right time to
participate in that the web is an
amazing force for good and evil it is a
toy and it's a tool it's a playground
and it's a marketplace it is alternately
amazing and terrifying in the power that
it gives us we can do so much good and
so much harm but I choose to believe
that in the long run we will
collectively decide to do more things
that help the world than hurt it we've
all made mistakes that hurt the world I
know that I have but I believe that in
the course of time our good decisions
will outweigh our mistakes and the web
will grow forever I hope what I've
shared with you today has helped you see
where you are and what you're doing and
I just hoped it's helped me I hope it's
helped motivate you and made you curious
and I hope you all have a fantastic day
scoff and thank you all so much for your
time and attention
[Applause]
[Music]